i know hans niemann is sitting in new
york city is that maybe
somewhere you shouldn't open the window
the best option might then be to open
the the doors and make sure that the air
you have in the apartment or wherever
you are to make sure that that air can
circulate and blend out the co2 levels
at least all right so now we know and
now the game has started david what are
we seeing on the board so far it's very
early days but it is the sicilian
defense and for those avid followers of
followers of chesapeal i know there's a
lot of them out there we know that
anishkiri is one of the biggest experts
in the world on this opening especially
with the black pieces he's published two
video courses one on the sicilian
najdorf actually the most popular
opening chess but also one on the
sicilian dragon so eric hansen with
white he's pausing he's actually
thinking already on just move three
i'm i'm surprised that he's surprised to
be honest but uh maybe he's just trying
to pick an opening where anishigiri will
be less familiar with the plans and he
doesn't go for the open sicilian trading
some pawns off in the center he goes for
maybe what's regarded as a quieter
simpler line he gives a check with the
white bishop and that check has been
blocked so things now will pursue maybe
a slower path and we'll just see the
players develop their pieces white's
king will come to safety soon and the
game will just maybe take a slower turn
at least for now and if you followed our
show uh
so far in the earth things monsters
maybe you noticed that we changed colors
to the bar the bar is now orange and the
bar is saying 0.7
for eric hansen is it too early to pay
attention to the bar
yes okay
so the evaluation by the orange bar does
show what the computer thinks of the
position right now it's on white side
but it's not by much 0.7 isn't a huge
amount if the bar gets a bit more
excited if it goes to plus 2 plus 3 for
white then we might take note
but right now it's too early to say
it depends on how
effective both sides plans are
especially as we enter the middle game
especially once both kings get to safety
at the moment it's very typical this
type of position and ivanka maybe you
have some stats on this but i've seen
this position before plenty of times and
my database is saying the same like 1
689 games have been played um actually a
little bit more than that i was just
looking at one particular line so you
know the pawn in the middle of the board
is under attack by the black knight and
now eric just has to make a choice is he
going to defend that pawn with his queen
by stepping it one square in front of
the king or maybe is it going to take a
slower approach and perhaps it will be
the queen's pawn that steps up one
square to defend it either way
the choice is in eric's hand is he gonna
go for
maximalist approach and that is defend
the pawn with the queen
or play a little bit more safely yeah
and we did just see eric there kind of
stared down he's kind of looking off to
the side looking down at the floor that
means he's just trying to remember what
he's studied in the past he's just
trying to
kind of activate the recall mode in his
brain
for sure he's seen this position before
he studied it before and as we see that
after a bit of thought after he'd
remembered what he planned to do he did
uh just play a few moves very very
quickly and uh and he continues to do
the same as well and he's actually
gaining some time from when he started
the game and uh yeah anish actually he's
one player i've noticed has probably the
worst co2 level out of all of the
players
and uh it has affected him somehow this
tournament so far
um
i know he's tweeted about it uh he said
you know there was a storm going on
outside maybe just some distractions but
uh
he's in an opening he likes right now
and maybe that will just help him at the
start of the day at least yeah and what
i really like about anish giri is he he
is a man of his his work he's done a
course on chesapore on this particular
opening called the night off and look at
him he's playing it
and uh this just shows that he believes
in his openings and he believes in the
lines that he's advocated all right
he's very principled he's also one of
the most hardworking
players in the world i don't know how he
does it he has a family he's producing
all these video courses for chessable
he's playing all the time i mean i
thought there was only 24 hours in the
day but
apparently not he probably has good air
quality you know keeps him energetic
throughout the entire day and i'm i'm
curious you again because eric hansen
and interrupt me now david of course if
some big moves happen but uh um he is
the player who's playing the earliest in
the morning in in canada is that an
advantage for him will air quality be
better
in the morning
probably because you spend the night in
another room yeah
unless he's in a hotel room or something
like that but that could definitely be
beneficial so sort of air quality it it
sort of resets after a long day and then
you you leave the room where you maybe
spend the whole day in home office or as
a chess player and then sort of the air
quality resets and get better well it
builds up if you spend time in a room
the room quality the air quality will
slightly
be worse worse over time uh so for sure
um
but i think uh opening up a window in
canada in the morning would definitely
give him a little bit of a boost
in the morning well could be one of the
reasons he's doing so fantastic in this
tournament eric hansen do you think he's
uh
do you think he's feeling good about the
opening here as well david yeah i would
be feeling great here with white if you
look at the center white has these two
very nice pawns in the middle of the
board this is one of the classic uh kind
of strategies we teach players when they
first learn the game just put your pawns
in the center bring your pieces out to
support those pawns
to safe squares centralized squares and
uh eric he's i've noticed especially
with white he's been this his whole
career he's been very classically
trained and he just likes to keep things
simple
gain gain the center maybe start
pressing from there but
the question is what to do next white
has done everything right so far the
computer evaluation is actually quite
far on white side already
this early in the game but the question
is what to do next when do you push
those white central pawns forward which
does involve some risk or do you just
build up first and he chooses to
centralize his rook at some point white
needs to wake up those pieces on the
left-hand side which are still faster
than sleep not really doing too much and
that's maybe why the computer's not such
a fan of this last move white's rook
it's on a decent square now but maybe it
was more urgent to improve the other
pieces which was still doing nothing at
home so early days still i don't want to
criticize either side's play but i do
slightly prefer white's position and i'm
going to give you a little bit of extra
information because we are actually
following a game that eric hansen
himself played against andre volikiten
is a grand master from the ukraine
in 2016 and he played this exact rook
move so
in that game in 2016 eric actually lost
with the black pieces with the white
pieces with the white white people yeah
with the white pieces and um so now he
has an improvement in store he wouldn't
just be repeating a line that he's lost
before
yeah it's a sense of desire deja vu for
eric hanson but it has cost him four
minutes to get to this position even
though he has seen it before even though
he knows it pretty well
and uh he's mentioned this in an
interview before time trouble is his
biggest weakness it's his achilles heel
so uh it is slightly surprising to me
that he's spent so long already he's
still got plenty of time for the rest of
the game 11 minutes you can get a lot of
moves on the board but
it is slightly worrying that he's
repeated an opening he's got a bad
experience in in the past and it's cost
him a few minutes to get here
thinking again now eric maybe a bit
nervous uh maybe it's the beginning of
the day a new day he's doing so well in
the tournament he just wants to
stabilize things but yeah that's
difficult in chess sometimes you just
have to trust yourself just have to play
quickly and save that time for later
and yeah i agree with david you know
as the day draws on i think he's going
to be feeling more more nervous because
it's just dawned on him you never
expected to do so well and now it's like
oh
touching distance with uh to getting
into the knockout stages
and talking about emotions i have to say
we love it when everyone at home gets
excited and joins in the conversation
sends us questions and sends us their
selfies yes and we have
in the meantime we do have a quick move
just a developing move from eric but we
do have a few selfies to show you and
i'm quite divine
says they are rooting for magnus carlsen
as always and they are watching from
cleveland ohio and febs avid is also
incredibly excited that is day three of
the champions chess tour and he's
watching from jeddah saudi arabia wow so
yeah if you want to join in the fun ask
us questions ask a question about chess
air quality and tweet us your selfies
and you can do all these things by using
the hashtag chesstamps
very cool yeah maybe some selfies you
know with a window to see where in the
world you're at what kind of weather it
is where you're where will it always be
better air quality outside
not in the city maybe no no there's some
uh places in the world where the air
pollution is is quite high yeah outdoors
that is true oh okay
couple of moves coming out here uh is
eric hanson finally starting to play a
little faster
he has sped up slightly eric but i'm not
100 sure um whether he's happy with the
developments in this game black is
starting to advance if you look at that
left side of the board black has pushed
a pawn there black's knight is slowly
edging
it's getting ready to enter white's half
of the board and
somehow it just feels like anishgiri
he's more familiar with the plans and
this position is all about planning only
one set of pawns have been traded so far
nearly every well everything else is
still on the board and that means
no action yet no tactics no fireworks
it's just about placing your pieces on
the best possible squares and anish he's
done that instantly he's improving his
pieces with every move eric just a bit
tentative just maybe unsure still what
to do with that white dart squared
bishop white's rook in the corner still
asleep
he needs to start waking those pieces up
and doing something within the next few
moves before anish is able to properly
activate and start challenging him in
the center and talking about doing
something i have three games on the
database uh michael adams irina bulmarga
and monica sachiko have these all the
grand masters have all played that they
haven't all played but they've all
played different things
and the results haven't been so good
actually two wins for black and one win
for white but the plan that catches my
eye is the plan that eric has just
played now which was actually employed
by michael adams in his game against uh
lenier dominguez in 2012 at the olympia
maybe david you can slightly recall that
game yeah i think i was sitting a couple
of seats away from that game and he came
up with this plan was just relocating
the bishop the bishop has gone on a huge
odyssey but the idea is actually now to
pick up the a pawn and once push it one
more square
and start disrupting
black's
fortress there on the left side
yeah so if you look at the bishop and
queen they're eyeing up these two pawns
right now the pawns are fortified
protecting each other but as ivanka
mentions if black is a bit slow if black
just kind of plays a move that doesn't
really do too much then white will push
forward and no matter what this pawn
does now there will be consequences if
you take white spawn for example now the
white bishop will pounce and after a
trade white's queen will enter the
action and this is just a trade still
level material but this black pawn now
extremely weak
ready to be picked off by white's knight
supported by the white rook and by the
white queen later on and this is a bit
of a deep idea by eric hansen
somehow to me it just shows that he has
studied this position before because the
move he has just played moving this
bishop again as white for i think it's
the fourth time in the game already
removing this bishop it's not obvious at
all and you only find a move like this
one if you've studied similar ideas in
the past but again that just
kind of raises the question why has he
spent so much time on the clock if he
knows the type of ideas he should be
aiming for anyway so white wants to play
this pawn move next and anishikiri will
maybe spend a couple of minutes trying
to find a solution he knows this move is
coming so he's just going to try and
work out what to do in reply over the
next couple of moves do you think eric
is nervous david basically because he's
now very aware that he is fighting in
the top
of the tournament and uh
just coming into today feeling a little
nervous yeah i've been there plenty of
times myself often you start a
tournament playing well the momentum's
on your side nothing seems to go wrong
every bit of luck seems to go your way
but then as soon as you get so close to
your kind of goal in the tournament here
for eric it's qualifying to the
knockouts he's only a couple of wins
away now but as soon as you get that
goal in your eyesight you get nervous
you get a bit tense you stop taking the
decisions you normally would make you
start playing safety first you start
spending a couple of extra minutes
unnecessarily and that could come back
to haunt you so okay meanwhile
anishigiri does plant his black knight
in white half of the board
blocking the effect of the white bishop
of the white queen that we highlighted
and uh
eric just takes the time out to play
another safety first move this is a move
we've mentioned before kaya right just
giving the white king some breathing
space so there'll be no checkmates on
the back rank later lift yes some ah
yeah it's on that square they have their
things device on the chessboard right
to measure there so david i have a
question um so is it easier for you for
you that is experienced uh to see who is
offensive defensive because i see the
bar in the top that goes back and forth
yeah
um that's a very good question actually
this type of position um
we tend to make generalizations if we're
just looking at it kind of from a
neutral point of view here i would say
for example i like white because white
has a nice pawn center in the middle of
these two white pawns they just control
lots of squares it's a bit like football
if you control the midfield you often
dictate the pace of the game you can
choose to play on the right on the left
in the center
so that's personally why i prefer
white's position but i think the
evaluation bar it's just showing that
neither player is playing perfect chess
but in this type of position they're not
making big mistakes either often there's
four or five good moves in the position
and as a human it's hard with only 10
minutes on the clock to choose uh
between those four or five options so
yeah um it's hard to criticize at the
moment the players
maybe they're not playing perfectly or
at least according to the computer but
they're just choosing plans that are
easy to understand for humans so um
neither side really on the attack or
defense yet okay they're just trying to
choose plans that are logical consistent
and maybe will guide them over the next
five or six moves so white for example
lining up the light squared bishop with
the queen black now just trying to bring
his pieces all over to this left side of
the board and so they're both a bit
hesitant definitely so we're waiting for
the braveheart moment where the clash
starts that's my favorite moment the
very far moment
yeah eric thinking again and you guys
you are both all three of you you're all
sort of geeks in your field right you're
all super into your field chess and air
quality how did you get into air quality
why on earth are you an air quality
expert
well i mean i have an engineering
background um so that means that you
know whatever it it
whatever topic becomes interesting i
want to dig into the details
um so joining air things and the
adventure over there obviously the first
thing one can do is to dig into
everything's uh uh you know the indoor
air quality and the impact it has on our
lives and all that stuff
definitely and i hear the ding he is
he's playing quite slowly eric hansen
but the move comes here yep um so every
time i hear you say the word ding i
think of the chinese but yeah we heard
that sound which means a move has been
made and again the evaluation bar not
sure that that's the best move but it is
quite illogical it is quite a human move
bringing the white bishop out to an
active square and now black has just
pushed a pawn there and white's well
white's bishop was under attack it has
retreated but there are pros and cons
behind black's last pawn push black's
king position now is slightly looser
slightly weaker than it previously was
that being said i don't really like the
position of white's bishop on the edge
of the board it could be very strong if
it can put pressure against black's
knight but at the same time the bishops
here are probably more important than
knights so you don't really want to
trade off and that white bishop is not
controlling any central squares and now
the computer really likes black i'm not
really sure why but uh maybe there are
some concrete reasons maybe the game
will start
livening up now maybe that braveheart
moment is coming anichigiri needs to
start taking some action against white
central pawns okay just a slow move
there just controlling some squares but
yeah this one is slowly bubbling it will
start to heat up soon yeah i agree um
yeah i have to say um i've once did this
exact same bishop maneuver that eric
hansen did and it got criticized by all
the grand masters it was in the british
championships when i was a teenager and
they said why is she wasting time with
this bishop and i really didn't like
this
bishop sortie and especially retweeting
to the edge of the board because i was
afraid that black could start simply
playing on the dark squares and just try
to lock that bishop out of the game yeah
and just to demonstrate this actually
maybe we can show yvanka's point because
black here
has just pushed his pawn forward i think
the move he wanted to play was to bring
his knight to the edge of the board and
we normally say knights on the rim are
dim you don't want to put your knights
on the side of the board because then
they only have one way back towards the
center knights are great in the middle
of the board but now the knight does
threaten to jump into the dark square
that ivanka mentioned this square the f4
square um is no longer protected by
white's bishop white bishop is simply
offside the reason anishigiri pushed the
pawn first is because actually this guy
is undefended and attacked so after the
move he's played pushing this pawn
forward there's a big question for eric
hanson now does he leave this bishop on
the square maybe just improve another
piece i mentioned this rook asleep at
home it can centralize itself but now
black's knight will come to the edge of
the board this bishop is hitting thin
air it looks great but it's actually
hitting nothing on this diagonal and now
black actually has a massive threat in
the position if white again doesn't do
too much for example just a nothing move
then the black knight will jump in and
look at these two pieces they attack so
many things here this knight attacks the
queen attacks the bishop if the queen
moves for example then the other knight
will start taking things start taking
some pawns and these two knights
combined they have entered white's
position and they will cause some real
damage so actually it's two or three
moves long but there is a small threat
in the position that eric hanson must
deal with after this pawn push he has to
be really worried now about black's
knight trying to do exactly what the
other knight has done and uh enter
white's half okay knights on the rim are
dim we have a bunch of these rhymes in
in chess and i
you mentioned at least one rhyme to
meworking before we went on the show
today rhymes and and puns about air
quality you had one that was really nice
did i yes what was it
the one that involved alcohol yeah
well
but that wasn't uh that wasn't a rhyme
but that was an interesting fact
actually it was right yeah yeah
so do you want me to share it yes
obviously um so well we do see that some
at some times these chess players have
um you know tendency of having the co2
levels go up above 1000 yeah ppm
and uh i read a study once that
you know the cognitive impact of the co2
levels going above 1000 ppm is
equivalent with drinking a pint of beer
that's incredible wow which means that
obviously if the co2 levels go up above
1000 ppm
you might have
obviously a a big big impact on decision
making the the ability to focus yeah uh
and all stuff that we know is super
important to to to win uh winning chess
okay so next time i make a mistake next
time i make a blunder i can blame it on
being drunk on the air exactly exactly
but there's a kind of i don't know
whether there's any scientific basis to
this but i've heard that when you
consume alcohol and play chess
your your tactics actually get better
but your strategical understanding goes
to pieces oh really yeah you cannot you
just cannot you don't have the
concentration to be able to sit there
and work things out logically you do
however have the ho-ho-ho let's give up
my creativity yeah but well i'm not sure
it's crazy creative maybe some because
you don't have that with co2 that's for
sure yeah okay exactly but
and yeah imagine like
parents sending their kids to school and
after an hour in a classroom probably
the co2 level can get really really bad
right
so it's basically like sending your kids
to school with
a pint of beer for breakfast exactly
air quality you guys it's super
important yeah because i have an air
things device a big fan in my office and
uh i it's always telling me giving me
warnings it's like hey your co2 levels
are too high go open a window and it's
quite funny actually because usually the
co2 levels get high when my husband
enters the room
and starts giving me some opinions on
some computer issues that i have and i'm
like suddenly my phone will go off
like you're reading too
too much exactly open the window or
leave
very harsh
yeah but it makes a big difference
fresher definitely well in this game the
bar is now i mean it's been so much
alive this game but now it's uh dead
zero draw it says
what do you think david yeah uh the
computer is so cynical yeah i guess
chess with best play by both sides
perfect play it is a draw so 0.0 makes
some sense but it just shows that both
sides they have followed logical plans
the position it's a bit of a standoff
right now
apart from black's knight which is in
white's half everything else by black is
kind of in his own camp everything for
white is in his camp as well and it's as
if both lines of the army are staring at
each other just too scared to make that
first move and actually there we see
black's kind of uh fearless warrior
retreat and uh take a step back into his
half so i'm not fully keen on that last
move by black i guess the black knight
wants to jump into a different square
this time to harass white uh white's
rook maybe to harass the central pawns
from the side but
either way yep very very tense it feels
as if neither side really wants to take
that next step really has a clear-cut
plan
of action next yeah i agree with you
david it's not necessarily clear what
both sides are going to be doing next
because like you say it's a clear battle
over strategies white is trying to do
everything to kem
he can to maintain that impressive pawn
center in the middle of the board black
on the other hand is going to try to
destabilize it with his pieces and he's
going to try to provoke one of those
pawns to come forward or simply take
control of that open sea line and uh as
you can see
i think eric is also struggling for a
plan because now he's just reacting to
anish's last move anish had a potential
threat with his knight
hopping into the board to attack the
rook and and eric just says
well i'm going to retreat my bishop
and cover that square
so just stopping the black knight coming
in and actually if anish giri wanted to
just tease his opponent here he could
bring that the knight back where it came
from attacking this pawn now the white
bishop would have to move so that the
white queen could defend this pawn the
black knight could step back again
trying to get to this square and we
could see the position repeat itself um
i don't think any wants a draw here
especially with black especially with
nearly five minutes extra on the clock
but then again he could at least just
tease eric here just say okay i'm gonna
bring the knight forward and then i'm
gonna try something else he's gonna
assert his dominance by saying okay i
could repeat the position go for a draw
but no i'm the one who's gonna play for
the win and
actually in the russian school of chess
they always advise that they say repeat
the position twice not a third time
don't go for the draw to show your
opponent you're in control it's a big
psychological uh trick so yeah right now
that's personally what i would have done
but okay anishigiri chooses a different
move instead of bringing the knight back
where it came from he pushes a pawn so
action is about to happen finally there
will be more trades i'm not sure this is
that great a move by uh anish but he
hope he's hoping at least that pawn
takes pawn will be played and now the
black queen would activate and start
attacking some pawns eric though does
have the option in this position after
this pawn push instead of capturing of
bringing his knight to the edge of the
board attacking the black queen and this
would cause some real complications the
black queen would offer to trade off
suddenly the white queen is hanging and
if we see an exchange then whose night
is weaker whose night is worse uh worst
placed i don't know to be honest but
either way neither knight makes a good
impression here and yeah things are
definitely starting to heat up after
this last pawn move we're finally
getting that action that we wanted for
so long definitely and uh how fast does
eric hansen have to play now with four
minutes left a little bit less than that
in move 21. it's worrying it's not just
that it's move 21 which is still quite
early in the game it's more that nothing
really has happened yet both sides
they've put their pieces on logical
squares and the top players they know
where their pieces belong they know
where they they want to kind of position
their army so that stuff is normally
automatic
but it's cost him most of his time
already just to get to this very
standard position and the fireworks
which are about to happen
he's not going to have much time at all
to calculate his way through them so
yeah i'm slightly worried this move i'm
not so keen on with black but i'm
slightly worried uh for eric in
practical terms because of the clock
yeah i agree david uh you know
the fireworks are going to happen now in
the next few moves and he's left himself
with so little time this is when
blunderville starts to happen take it
from me this has been the story of my
last two tournaments spent too much time
trying to be perfect in the opening and
maybe the early middle games and then of
course you know around move 30 or so
things
the tempo starts to increase and then
ah
i don't know i blended yeah and the game
just kind of changes completely i can
actually relate to that as well you know
you know for example getting ready for
these shows planning these shows i want
to do it perfect so i spend so much time
and then suddenly it's two hours until
we go on go live and i just i'm halfway
through the show and i just don't have
time it's about being too perfect and
you know when you start planning stuff
and uh actually we mentioned the seven
deadly chest since the book by jonathan
rousen that is a sin perfectionism ah is
it you can't be too perfect in chess
there's no such thing as keeping control
for an entire game especially at this
level your opponents are too good to let
you uh keep that control so at some
point things will get messy they will
get complicated and things got messy now
on the board we did actually see that
variation that i highlighted with the
queens coming down getting traded off
for each other and white's knight was
attacked on the edge of the board it's
come in but now eric has two minutes and
a bit of a shaky position white's knight
might have just trapped itself
uh in black's camp it's getting
adventurous it's getting aggressive that
white knight attacking black's rook but
it's a lone ranger it has no support and
if any giri chooses uh the correct
continuation now actually i see a few
tempting moves then i think white's
knight might be in big trouble what has
ennis played wow he's just left his rook
attacked this is really clever we have
to show on the board um
yeah perfectionism for eric it didn't
pay off because i think he's in trouble
right now actually in this position we
just backtrack one move this rook was
attacked it's human nature
if you see your idea you think okay my
opponent has to react to it but
sometimes you forget your opponent has
threats as well so
in answer to this attack there is a
counter-attack the rook didn't move
black just stepped to pawn forward one
square and now if the rook is captured
black will say okay i don't care about
this knight yet i'm gonna flick in pawn
takes bishop first and after the pawn is
recaptured because it's attacking
white's rook now the knight will be
taken and if we do a quick count black
actually has a bishop and a knight for a
rook and if you if we
do a bit of maths there a knight in
bishop worth six a rook worth five two
pieces as well better than one and black
has the advantage so eric now in a bit
of trouble now if he has to move this
bishop for example then the rooks will
come off and at the very end
white will lose a pawn for free so he's
about to lose material
and look at the clock it's ticking down
to one and a half minutes what's going
to happen with the air around eric
counts now that he he starts sweating
maybe breathing faster
will it change the air around him as
well absolutely i mean him breeding
faster is going to produce more co2
that's for sure
maybe his body heat
you know will impact the overall thermal
comfort so there's stuff happening in
that room that's for sure he actually
looks kind of calm though but there's
drama on the board david there's a lot
of drama on the board as we mentioned
white's knight was doomed
that transition actually happened the
knight grabbed the black rook the white
bishop fell
white's knight decided to flick in a
check first but it has just dropped off
the board so it's that material
imbalance that i mentioned white
actually has an extra pawn now so it's a
rook and a pawn for black's bishop at
night but in general the pieces are
better black's bishop and knight
combined will overpower one of the white
rooks and
okay eric steps forward a pawn that was
just attacked in the center he's trying
to complicate things now because
long term he's just lost black is
winning long term but short term maybe
white has some chances and uh now he's
just trying to make anish a bit confused
with this pawn push he's attacking one
of the black knights attacking one of
the black pawns
it feels like a niche with eight minutes
though should be able to re-establish
control and then his extra pieces will
decide the game so
looking very difficult for eric hanson
and uh not much to say about his
position i don't think he will save this
one if anish just captures a pawn in the
center maybe centralizes the black
knight that's under attack as well at
some point and slowly but surely
um the black pieces will start to take
over white's rooks then just not
combined and even if one of the white
rooks comes up the board to try and
check the black king at the very best
it's just going to get traded off yeah
it's the rooks just don't have the
mobility to be a powerful i mean the
rooks really want to have uh
to the power to traverse the board
horizontally horizontally
the wrong movement there horizontally
and vertically as well and especially
horizontally because there it can switch
between the two flanks and if you see
here
well he can't do that it's only going to
go one way and eric really to his credit
you know he's kind of in hustle mode
he's uh trying to create those
complications because he knows
ultimately if he lets anish consolidate
then he's going to lose yeah and anyone
who's watched eric online he's got a
huge online following as a streamer
anyone who's seen his youtube channel
his videos knows that he's a fighter
actually whenever he wins a game he has
this kind of mortal combat
signal at the end where it's like ko
game over
he will fight to the bitter end and
actually yesterday as well he had some
bad positions but he saved them so um
yeah i think black should be winning
with perfect play but
humans are not perfect especially with
no time and it doesn't seem that anish
made the perfect move there the bar
reacted a little bit yeah i think maybe
there was a better square for black's
knight he went for the most human move
but now eric getting active with one of
the white rooks and uh we mentioned that
was the key and ivanka mentioned the
rooks if they can't find good squares
it's just gonna be no chance for white
but uh he's trying at least to activate
one piece and black's pawn now next to
the black next to the white rook sorry
is under fire
um yep still some chances i like
eric's last move at least
and uh anish meanwhile
maybe not feeling 100 confident just
because he's had such a difficult
tournament so far
and uh winning a one position they do
say that's the hardest thing in chess
it's easy to build it up it's easy to
trick your opponent sometimes but
putting the finishing touches on
putting the ball in the back of the net
you do get nervous sometimes and uh your
opponent always has defensive tricks
well anish he really uh you know upped
his game in online rapid chess last year
becoming one of the best players in the
tour but uh what is he
he is you know just just about inside
top eight before the start of today what
has he struggled a little bit with this
tournament uh consistency in a way
actually especially on day one he wasn't
as solid as he usually is anish giri
when we think of him i mean some people
make jokes about draws but it just shows
that he nearly never loses he's very
resourceful he's a fighter himself uh
he's very well prepared in the opening
very well trained uh very disciplined as
well but it feels like on day one he
lost a bit of discipline he was taking
risks and they were backfiring maybe
because of the new format of the tour uh
but uh yesterday he did stabilize a bit
and play a bit better so
um yeah he's just a great player
i mean he barely has any weaknesses to
his game but uh yeah so far just not
quite at his best well a win here would
be great news for anish geary eric
hansen he is in the third place before
the start of today he can afford a loss
but obviously one point and a draw
is what he
well he wants to win but is that
possible still for him or what kind of
results can be possible in this game now
well there's still a plenty of
opportunity for both sides to go wrong i
mean this is a very imbalanced position
it's a rook and a pawn against two minor
pieces and so far in this current
position you can actually see that eric
eric's rook is attacking the pawn and so
that's the immediate question and it's
not particularly easy for a niche to
actually defend that pawn in a safe way
i mean if he defends it with his bishop
moment well he'll have to put the bishop
on the edge of the board
and uh also take a look at the knights
you know there's two pieces there on the
edge and we're never big fans of those
pieces with no squares exactly black
still needs at least two or three moves
to re-centralize these pieces later also
black has to be a bit careful of the
dark squares this bishop is offside not
doing too much it's actually searing its
own pawn so it's blocked in right now
but if your careless is black it could
come to life for example there are some
annoying checks that could happen at
some point this looks like like a nasty
skewer
checking the king and if the king moves
then the rook will drop off behind it
but at the moment it's okay for black
because black would be able to block
this attack and that's why eric has
played his last move i was about to
suggest it this pawn push forward it has
a sneaky idea in mind and that is simply
if black does nothing if black kind of
centralizes the knight then now white
would be winning white would turn things
around completely with a check and this
skewer now is super effective because
this pawn push would not effectively
block
white could just capture it and after a
trade again check and blackstroke would
fall off so
nasty nasty threat in the position eric
hansen very sneaky now with this pawn
push he's not just solidifying his
center he's creating this idea of a
check and that's not actually easy for
any to deal with maybe he just has to
get his king out of the eye line of that
bishop get it onto a light square where
it will be safe for example retreating
and if the white bishop does now move
okay he's gone for a different option
but now i was gonna say he could move
the rook he chooses the
kind of reverse idea he moves the rook
first out of the way so in this position
will we see a rook trade after the rook
comes across no eric gives a check and
now the black king will simply move and
if these rooks disappear off the board i
think black will be much happier because
this after all is white's best piece
okay
well levon aronian great start to the
day for him winning his first game
against young christoph duda duda really
struggling so far in the air things
masters
anish geary fighting for a win and his
first game of today against eric hansen
clock ticking for him as well now is it
important average to keep the speed up
to keep that time advantage i think
ideally he would like to because eric
hansen is one of the best players in the
world actually at what we call bullet
jazz where both sides start with just
one minute on the clock he is so fast so
tricky he's got great instincts uh eric
hansen so it would just become a lottery
it will just become very random if both
sides have less than one minute um i
think actually i would favor eric if
anything uh if it's just about the speed
but uh while anish has a few minutes
more he uh will be pretty confident 15
seconds though for eric hanson
this is getting intense
it is getting intense because uh eric is
certainly on the back foot as well
yeah five seconds the problem is he
can't choose those simple moves two
seconds i think he's because what
well two seconds and he's just given up
his rook for a knight and
porn desperation right that's
desperation right now if we do a quick
count black has an extra night just for
two white pawns yes the night isn't
great right now but if it does
centralize itself if it does find an
outpost later attacking some of the
white pawns actually can do that now the
knight can re-centralize itself
yeah it's going to
far
far outweigh those white pawns i just
got one thing that anish has to be
absolutely careful he must not take his
rook off the bottom row if he lifts that
rook and moves it anywhere other than
the eighth row then there is going to be
something that we call the opera mate it
was based on a story from actually
something that happened to a legendary
player in the 18th century paul morphy
he he beat the duke of brunswick in the
18th century at the opera
so we call this checkmate the opera mate
so don't fall into it yeah this is a
very common checkmating pattern a niche
will definitely not fall in uh full for
it but this is one to remember at home
because uh it happened to me i remember
when i was very young in a few
of my first tournaments so um yeah right
now in the current position the black
rook is tied down to defend this back
rank to prevent that from happening and
meanwhile anishigiri does centralize his
knight attacking some of these pawns and
actually this point does step forward so
offering up a bit of bait do you take
this pawn but re-sideline your knight
again
it looks perfectly fine to me to be
honest you can get greedy here but greed
isn't always good and the other
alternative would be to centralize the
knight attacking the white rook and if
the white rook goes back then suddenly
the black bishop can re-enter the game
you could team up against this pawn with
your knight your bishop and suddenly
yeah the knight can also dance back and
attack this bishop it feels like black's
pieces are starting to coordinate
and uh yeah once that happens i think
anish will win yeah but i'm curious will
he grab the pawn agreed will he
will he find that pawn irresistible and
the answer is no he decides to put his
knight in the center and go for the plan
that david highlighted which would look
really quite ruthless
yep and that was another of the seven
deadly chess sins materialism greed
sometimes there are more important
factors than material
than just mere pawns on the side of the
board
and yep white's rook is under fire two
seconds again by eric oh he made the
move with two seconds left on his club
real brinksmanship by hanson and i mean
he's so calm look at him just so focused
despite having two seconds left
i mean i'm in trouble all the time but i
still have my heart beating
way too fast uh when i'm down under five
seconds and okay he does treat his rook
i mean it looks like it is an ishkiri
who's in time trouble look at him he's
you know fidgety and he you know his
face seems a little red and he seems to
be a little nervous
maybe it's the co2 levels uh
yeah increasing that pint of beer yeah
exactly he's getting drunk on here
yeah actually i saw at the beginning of
play his co2 levels for about 750 oh no
see and they're over 1 000 so oh that's
bad news he's intoxicated he needs to
hurry up
that's actually a red ring around the
co2 level is it
that's bad news for a niche geary and
one thing i noticed on last season of
the tour um okay the knight just
maneuvering around now attacking some
pawns one thing i noticed last season is
that anish struggled in tournaments when
his co2 co2 levels were high the one
tournament he won the magnus castle
invitational actually he had great co2
levels for most of it so uh
maybe it's coincidence maybe not i don't
know
absolutely not right yeah it's uh it's
certainly affected my notice towards the
end of most days um often he starts
quite well but then
can be a struggle to maintain his form
yeah i think it's a key point uh bad air
quality affects your endurance
and ability because remember these are
long tournaments these are long days you
know four games of high quality
and the high emotion yeah big stakes as
well
so yeah the nerves are going to get to
him and bad air quality yeah meanwhile
things have taken a turn for the worst
on the board as well for eric hanson a
pawn has dropped so the opera checkmate
that ivanka highlighted
that is off the table it's gone look at
the black knight just blocking the white
rook
it's also supported by black's bishop
everything's teamed up for black the
black bishop supporting the black knight
which just cuts the board in half in a
way stops any of white's play and
now this black pawn that has pushed it's
running down the board black is just a
piece up and have we seen eric hansen
resign he's just given up it's a
difficult position but a bit too early
anishikari though takes the win